[Music]
hi everyone I'm Leon feibish and again
first I want to thank you all for
joining my talk today we are going to
talk about keeping sensitive data safe
using recommendation systems
so let's talk a bit about recommendation
systems this is me and usually in
Netflix I like watching romantic
comedies such as those movies
so it will be nice from Netflix to
recommend me more of those movies that
I'll probably like to watch like this
one
that's the basic of recommendation
systems so just in few item that you'll
probably like based on your previous
based on your previous preferences
it could be in a various soft Fields
like videos Foods clothes and so on
now if we are back to our Netflix
example what if someday I watched some
documentary about the French Revolution
is not connected to my previous movies
and is not aligned with my previous
preferences
of course it could be someone else who
is using my accounts or is just me who
wants to to try new things and watch
something different
but in both cases this scenario doesn't
represent my regular behavior and there
is something weird that's going on
but you're not here to get new movies
recommendations you can do that later
we're here to talk about information
security and about protecting the data
in our organizations
altered these two subjects
recommendation systems and anomaly
detection
don't seems to be related to each other
in this talk I'll show you how you can
twist recommendation 50 methods and do
that in an opposite direction in order
to protect your organization and keep
your data safe and secure
you will see that sometimes you need to
go the opposite way in order to get to
the right direction
now a few words about myself
I'm a data scientist on paper for the
past six years
I am part of the Instagram of disabled
security threat oversight team which is
part of the information security
organization
or a team of security researchers or
each one has a different perspective and
unique point of view in order to cover
as many security issues as possible
my role is finding machine learning
solutions for information security
problem and in addition I have MSA and
information systems and software
engineering from Ben Gurion University
so our objective for today is to learn
and understand how we can protect our
organization and the sensitive data in
it
many organizations are using a massive
amount of data for their day-to-day job
and usually most of the organizations
are using databases to store the data
and users are performing queries in
order to access extract or update the
data
sometimes this data might be sensitive
and shouldn't be exposed to all users
for example data like passwords phone
numbers addresses and accounts is very
sensitive and shouldn't be exfiltrated
out to out of the organization
keeping this data safe and secure is one
of the main issues that most of the
organization needs to deal with because
it can cause a real damage to the
company if this data is leaking out to
the wrong hands
so the problem we are trying to solve is
the need to improve the control we have
in the organization on our sensitive
data
it means that we need to find a way for
keeping this data safe and prevent
potential security incidents and any
possible misusage of this data
it means that we need to make sure that
only authorized users will access it and
detect any different behaviors in the
user's data access patterns
in this talk I'll show you how you can
use recommendation system methods for
the problem of anomaly detection and how
it can help us detecting unauthorized
access to our databases
at the beginning we will talk about
recommendation systems in general and
specifically about implicit feedback and
its implementation in Python
afterward we will talk about the domain
of databases access and how we can use
the recommendation system for detecting
anomalies in that domain and I'll show
you the experiments I made and how it's
proving the accuracy of the method
so let's start with recommendation
systems
as I mentioned earlier
in recommendation systems usually we
have several items and the goal is to
predict a rating a user would give to
each item and suggest relevant items for
him
the most popular method for finding
those recommendations is called the
collaborative filtering which based on
the Assumption the people that people
who agreed in the past will tend to
agree in the future
collaborative filtering similarity
scores between users and items in order
to provide recommendations
for example if we have two users we
usually it's a burger and the salad
every day and one user is buying a cake
for dessert one day
so it will be probably a good option to
suggest the other user to buy a cake for
dessert as well
there are two types of feedback when
talking about recommendation systems one
is explicit feedback where we have a
direct input from the users regarding
their preferences
this way this way we know exactly how
much a user like or dislike a particular
item by providing a numerical writing to
it
for example a user is writing a movie
phone from one to five stars or writing
additional restaurants from one to ten
according to how much he likes it
but users probably don't want to spend
time writing the items they are using so
usually this type of feedback is hard to
get
another type of feedback which is more
popular is implicit feedback where all
we have is only the users and the items
interaction
it is Data We Gather from the user's
Behavior with no writings or specific
actions needed from the user
for example if a user has watched a
movie for five times the system infer
that the user is interested in it
more example of implicit feedback could
could be items the user purchased there
are many times they play the song go
watch the movie How much time they spend
or even reading a specific article and
so on
the upside of implicit feedback is that
we have a lot more data but the downside
is that it's way more noise and we can't
always understand its meaning
for example with stars writing we know
that one star means that the user didn't
like that item and 5 Star 5 Stars means
that they really loved it
but when watching a movie it could be
that the user watched it and hated it or
loved it or somewhere in between
and if we didn't watch the movie at all
it might be since he doesn't like it or
that he would love it if he just knew
about it
later in this talk I'll explain how we
can overcome this problem
here in our domain the type of the data
we are dealing with is implicit data
there are a lot of methods for
calculating those writings one of them
is called Matrix factorization
in this method the past writings are
stored in a sparse user item Matrix
where each cell stands for the rating a
user is giving to an item
and the Matrix is sparse because each
user has only few related items and
usually there are no users awaited all
items
The Matrix factorization method suggests
using low dimensional representation of
users and items in a shared latent
factor space
and by using those user items like
latent spice we can unfair infer
unobserved preferences
the idea is basically to take the large
user write a metrics and Factor it into
some smaller representation of the
original data
and the multiplication of the user and
the item matrices gives us the predicted
writing Matrix
for example in order to calculate the
predicted writing a user U would give to
an itemi we need to calculate the
multiplication of all u in the user's
Matrix with column I in the items Matrix
which is the UI cell in the predicted
writing Matrix
so the goal is that they predicted
directing metrics will reflect the two
preferences of the users
common loss function for user U and
itemi can be expressed as the following
well if we are trying to minimize the
squared error of the difference between
the real writing and the predicted
writing which is the dot product of the
user and the item vector and in addition
there is also the regularization term in
order to prevent overfitting
minimizing this formula using the
regular optimization methods works
better for explicit feedback but doesn't
work well when dealing with implicit
feedback data
the main difference between implicit and
explicit feedback is how we are dealing
with missing values
in explicit data is just unknown data
but with implicit feedback we cannot
assume that since there are some
information in these unknown values so
we need to find the way to learn from
the missing data
the approach we are going to use here
with our the implicit data set is based
on the method mentioned in the paper
collaborative filtering for implicit
feedback data sets
in the method mentioned in the paper
they used binary preference as the user
observed the item or not
and the image that preference with the
way to the with the weight of confidence
we have for that score which is the
strength of the preference
missing values are negative preference
with low confidence and existing values
are positive preference but with the
high confidence value
in the paper they used rui for
representing the observation for user
actions
for example in the domain of watching
movies rui could be the amount of times
user you watched movie I
the next Formula is Pui which is the
preference of user here to item I and is
equal to one if rui is greater than zero
which means that the user consumed the
item I or would be equal to zero if the
user didn't interact with the item at
all
later we are calculating the confidence
cui is equal to 1 plus Alpha multiplied
by rui
the confidence is higher when the user
interacts more with the item and use it
more often
and the rate that the confidence
increases is set using a linear scaling
Factor Alpha and I also added one in
order to have a minimal confidence even
if R is equal to zero
now we are trying to minimize the
following cost function which is the
confidence multiplied by the square
difference between the preference and
the dot product of the user and item
vectors and again adding the
regularization term
this cost function depends on M and N
where m is the number of users and N is
the number of items and even for typical
data sets M multiplies n can easily be
can easily reach a few billion and the
regular optimization method such as
stochastic gradient descentes GD
wouldn't work well for this type of data
therefore in the paper they offer to use
an alternative optimization method which
is the alternate list squared algorithm
ALS
this method suggests fixing each factor
at a time and if we are fixing the user
factors or the item factors we can
calculate the global minimum
it means that we are alternating between
recomputing the user factors and the
item factors and when fixing either the
user of the item factors the cost
function became quadratic so its Global
minimum can be easily computed and each
step is guaranteed to lower the value of
the cost function
the full mathematical calculation of
demand of this method is out of the
scope of that presentation and you can
read about it later
so now after solving everything and
calculated the matrices we can finally
move to the recommendation process
in Python there is an implementation of
this algorithm in the implicit Library
this Library provides first python
implementation of several different
popular recommendation algorithms for
implicit feedback data sets and one of
them is the alternating list scores
algorithm as described in the paper
in order to install it you just need to
do prep installing place it and you'll
be able to import it and use it
for using the ALS algorithm you need to
initialize the model first using
implicit.als.alternate English square
and then choose the number of factors
which is the number of latent features
to compute then choose the
regularization factor to use and also
choose the number of ALS iterations to
use when fitting the data
later we need to create the confidence
Matrix so we are choosing the alpha
value which here is 40. and multiply it
by multiply it by the sparse user item
Matrix
then we are fitting the data to the
model using this confidence metrics and
creating our model
and now that we have the trained model
we can move to the recommendation
we can recommend items for the user
using the recommend function
we are choosing the user we want to
recommend the items to and we are also
choosing them the number of items to
recommend and the function also needs
the original user item Matrix in order
to filter out the already used items
the function calculates the top and best
recommended items for the user and
returns a list of items like this and
the corresponding score for each item
for example item number 566 received a
score of 0.86 Which is higher than the
item 166 received which is 0.7
one more interesting function is the
rank items function where you can choose
a user and a set of items you want to
rank and the model will calculate their
score and rank the items according to
the preference of the user
again the function Returns the IDS of
the items along with the score
as you can see the scores aren't always
between 0 and 1. it happens because
there is no explicit scale here the
scores are used only for ranking then
sorting the recommendations where the
higher score means the most recommended
item
when calculating the dot product of the
users and the item vectors we are trying
to make it as close as possible to the
real preferences but since there are no
boundaries it can take any possible
value
by finding the optimal parameters we are
pushing those values close to 0 and 1
but when adding the regularization term
and the confidence weight those
additional factors may push them in
different directions so we don't always
end up with zero to one values
so now that we know how recommendation
system works and how to use it properly
we can move to the real problem where we
are here to talk about which is keeping
our data safe and analyzing our
databases access patterns
our domain is databases access and the
actions we observe are users who access
to tables and extract or update the data
in it
so our objects are users and tables and
the relationship is that the users are
consuming the tables so the tables are
the items
users are accessing to table using
queries so we are looking on the amount
of queries each user performed on each
table and that would be our implicit
feedback
in general high amount of queries on the
tables means that the user liked the
table it's relevant for him but if there
is a low amount of queries on a table it
means that the user dislikes the table
or as we discussed few minutes ago it
may be because he needed it only for a
few times
in addition if the user didn't access a
table at all it could be because this
table is irrelevant to him or because he
didn't knew about it or didn't have the
chance to use it yet
and again that's exactly why in the
algorithm we are using they added the
confidence value on the user preference
and in the cases where we don't have
many interactions with the table the
confidence will be low
so the problem we are trying to solve is
to solve here is the is finding the
anomalies in those actions of accesses
to tables
basically it is events of unexpected or
unauthorized access to tables for
example if someone is working on a
project of Type X is usually accessing
tables that related to this project X
because that's what he needs to perform
his job
but what if what does what if suddenly
is accessing all tables which doesn't
relate to his project and doesn't relate
to her to any one of his team members
project and might contain sensitive data
that he doesn't supposed to have access
to at all
for example we don't want someone from
the user interface team in Netflix we'll
access the customer's data
this data isn't relevant for user
interface and there is no excuse for
this user to access this data
so we need to prevent those events and
keep our data safe
we should create an alert for those kind
of actions so we'll be able to protect
this data and make sure it doesn't
exfiltrate it out of the organization
but our recommendation system related to
all of it and how it can help us solve
our problem
as we mentioned the Bob our goal is
detecting anomalies in the user's usage
patterns detect when the user is
behaving differently from the way it's
supposed to behave and Performing
actions that doesn't fit with his
previous actions
usually in recommendation systems we are
looking for items that the user is
supposed to like and recommend it to him
but here in this case we are looking for
the outliers which is the opposite
direction of recommendations the items
that the user is unlikely to use
and that's what I want you to take from
that presentation that sometimes you
need to switch your algorithm and use it
in an opposite way in order to solve
your problem
for example in the movies domain instead
of focusing on movies the user would
like we are looking for the least
expected movies with the lowest
probability that this user would watch
think about me with the French
documentary movie we talked about I want
to know when there is a change in the
user's Behavior
so in our solution we are looking for
those unrecommended items that the user
is not supposed to use
and the alert One is using those items
and might cause dangerous consequences
to the organization
so we need to build a recommendation
model based on the databases access logs
we need to count the amount of queries
each user performed on each table and
this will be our implicit data which is
the sparse user item Matrix
we are building the ALS implicit model
using the python Library we are setting
the values for the regularization term
the regularization factor the number of
ALS iterations the number of latent
factors and the value of alpha it is of
the value of the scaling Factor Alpha
we decided to train the model using six
months of queries data so we'll have
enough data for training the model
we also decided to count new access to a
table only if the user is accessing the
table using different queries on the
same day
it means that if the user is using the
same query for several times in the same
day we will count it only once but in
the next day it will be count again as a
new query
we did that because we wanted to remove
automated queries that runs the same
query over and over again
and create a really high amount of
access to tables it creates a lot of
noise in the data and we wanted to
reduce that noise and make the model as
close as possible to the real access
patterns
in addition we also set a threshold for
minimum access for users and tables and
we filtered out real users
everyone is good
um
okay so we filtered out their user who
accessed only a few tables and also
tables that almost no users have access
to
so now we have a trained model that can
calculate recommendations but how can we
know that it is actually working
in order to prove the accuracy of the
model we perform two experiments where
we tested the output of the model
in the first experiment we simulated
multiple accesses to tables and check
the score the model gave to each item to
each axis we created a test set of 500
events of user to access to tables and
we decided to consider for the test set
only events of users who access to a
tables for more than 10 times so we'll
be able to be sure that this table is
indeed relevant for the user
we chose those events because we are
dealing with implicit data and if we are
choosing the user who access to a table
only once it could be because we access
it by mistake and it's irrelevant to him
and we wanted to be sure that we are
testing only known preferences
so we turn the model using the access
data and then we calculated this course
for the test set and plotted the results
on The Following histogram
almost all of the observation received
high score around one which indicates
the accuracy of the model since it means
that the model is predicting the scores
correctly according to the real
preference of the user because we chose
for the test set only items that we know
for sure that the user actually liked
because they used it for more than 10
times
the second experiment we made is based
on the assumption that it in the world
of databases access similar users who
works on the same team or works in the
same types of project will access the
same groups of table that related to
their project or to their team
and the outliers are when someone is
accessing the tables that he didn't
access before and it doesn't relate to
any other of his previous tables or to
any of the tables of his similar User
Group
so in order to simulate good and bad
access to tables we are choosing 500
random users and for each other we are
choosing two unseen tables that this
user never accessed before
the first table is taken from the group
of tables that each team already
accessed and used and the second table
is taken from the group of tables that
no one from his team accessed before
now we are feeding those scenarios into
the model and we are calculating this
cause
in order to evaluate the results we
calculated the kernel density of the
estimation of this course and as can be
seen in the graph the blue tables which
are the tables taken from the same team
receive dire scores than the red tables
that was taken from other users
you can say the separation between the
blue and delay tables and now the
outliers we simulated receive the lower
score than the blue relevant tables
in addition you can see that most of the
scores in the red group are around zero
and most of the scores in the blue group
are around 1.
it means that the model indeed was able
to identify the suspicious access to the
unexpected tables and separate those
scores from the good data
in addition we also calculated the ROC
curve and the AUC and it was around 90
which is another another indicator that
our ALS model is working the way we
wanted it to work
so now we have a system that gets us
input and access to a table process it
through the model and generate a score
for each axis and this call indicates
how normal or abnormal this axis is
and in order to find the anomalies we
need to set a threshold based on the
model this based on the score of the
model calculated
and if there is a new access to a table
that receives the score Above This
threshold it's a normal event and if it
receives a score below this threshold
it's an anomaly
I also wanted to share that after
creating this project testing the model
and evaluating it me and my colleagues
in PayPal decided to file this idea as a
patent in the U.S patent office and now
you can find it and read all about it in
Google patents
possible future steps on this area could
be using this mechanism for the granting
access process in the organization
for example if a user is requesting gain
access to a specific table we can
calculate the score for that access and
if this score is low which means that
the probability that this table is
relevant for that user is low
maybe we should ask his manager before
granting that access to him
one more thing could be learning and
getting insights from this course and
leverage team collaborations
for example creating a team's clusters
according to their preference vectors
and suggest those teams which is in the
same cluster to collaborate and learn
from each other since they are working
on the same type of data
obviously there are some challenges in
this method for example possible
challenge could be that that we have
different level of sensitivity for each
table and that each table should be
handled in a different way
we can identify the set of sensitive
data and give it smaller threshold so
we'll be able to control the sensitivity
of that access
and tables that contains more sensitive
data will get more focused while tables
with regular data will get higher
threshold
this way we can play with the threshold
in order to control the noisiness of the
alerts according to the sensitivity of
the data
another challenge could be changes
inside the organization employees were
moving from one team to another changes
of responsibilities and so on
this could confuse the model because now
we have users who access to tables that
are far from their previous tables
we can solve this problem by defining
some Grace time when we are learning the
new vectors again and canceling the
alert for dollars from the team for a
while until we are learning the new
updated vectors
for conclusion if there is one thing I
want you to take from that presentation
is that sometimes you need to go the
opposite way in order to solve your
problem and to get to the right
direction
I presented the idea of using
recommendation systems for the problem
of anomaly detection
we talked about recommendation systems
in general and specifically about
implicit feedback and the ALS algorithm
later we discussed about how can we use
this algorithm for databases access
problem and about using the opposite
direction the direction of the
recommendation process in order to find
anomalies instead of recommendations
now we can detect unauthorized access to
our data to our tables get a score for
each new access and alert or block that
event accordingly
and one you once you'll Embrace this way
of thinking and implementing the into
your algorithm the main aspects I just
covered we will all get safer
organizations and better Protections in
our data
thank you for listening to my talk if
you have any questions
[Music]